what if you could eradicate genetic
disease and what if you could design
humans to be superhuman well this is no
longer science fiction scientists are
both excited and concerned that a new
technology for modifying genes will
change who we are faster and more easily
than ever before here's how it works
every cell in your body contains a copy
of your genome about 20,000 genes three
billion letters of DNA with this new
method called CRISPR cast nine
geneticists can find cut out and replace
any part of the genetic code of any
species including humans this kind of
editing could correct genes that lead to
lethal diseases before birth if a person
had a genetic disease caused by a single
faulty gene CRISPR could be used
eliminated from that person's children
and how easy is it to do this very says
the scientists responsible for Co
developing the CRISPR editing system in
fact it's already being done in China
where the DNA of early stage IVF embryos
is being edited using CRISPR a group of
American scientists wants to suspend
attempts to create what are being called
genetically modified children until the
safety and medical reasons behind it can
be better understood almost nothing is
known about the consequences of altering
human DNA and attempts to do so are
bound to have unpredictable results